when did you start calling yourself a
screenwriter
probably my second or third script like
my first script it was kind of
you know i was writing about like a
personal experience and i was just kind
of it was almost like therapy for me at
the time
and so then probably my second script
i was an aspiring screenwriter like i
was like oh this is fun i want to do
this
and i probably got my third maybe fourth
script is when i was like oh yeah i'm a
screenwriter i'm not getting paid yet
but i'm a screenwriter like this is
where i'm going
uh and then my fifth script was a paid
script so i was like i
already made it come true awesome it
wasn't very big paid because it was a
small like local person i think it got
paid like 500 bucks or something like
that
um to write a feature uh that never got
made
so but yeah i probably my third or
fourth script is when i went from being
an aspiring experience like yes this is
what i'm
doing with my life did someone say
to you don't call yourself an aspiring
writer oh you will always get haters
who say like if you're not making money
at it you shouldn't call yourself a
screenwriter like
uh you know they're like oh you wouldn't
call yourself a plumber because you
fixed your own toilet well
i'm still writing screenplays and you
know i'm not doing it just for myself
i'm
still trying to get my stuff out into
the world whether it's being paid or not
because you know when writing a spec
script
you're not paid paid through writing
that spec so are you not a screenwriter
because it hasn't sold yet like you
still wrote the thing
it takes time effort energy heart blood
soul everything goes into these scripts
you know so you're absolutely if you're
if you're actually doing the work you're
absolutely a screenwriter
um i feel like the only way that you're
not is if you're someone who
says you're a screenwriter and aren't
doing any work towards it i've met
people who are like i'm a screenwriter
okay great
what have you worked on oh well i
haven't read anything yet but i want to
be
welcome to los angeles exactly right
yeah uh i
i heard um you know on twitter i follow
a lot of
show runners and and stuff like that and
uh there was a showrunner i'm trying to
remember who it was now that it was like
a couple weeks ago
that they met someone at a party um they
knew who she was
and what show she was on and they're
like oh well you know i would love to
write on your show that it's fantastic
and they had built a rapport before we
brought it up which is good
um and then she said okay well sure send
me over a sample
he didn't have any samples he had not
written a single thing but he's telling
her how much he wants to write for her
show
wow and yeah it's like why why are you
bringing that up if you don't have
anything to to show and prove yourself
you know to them
um because like oh well in that case i
want to go and play
you know baseball but i don't have the
experience on it i want to
so as soon as you're doing the work
you're a screenwriter
okay that makes sense and so what i was
also wondering is did did you feel like
you held yourself back because you were
calling yourself
for i think after your second script and
aspiring right i don't think i was
holding myself back i think it was uh
i think it was more of like i didn't
have the nerve to call myself that yet
because i was so inexperienced um and i
wasn't sure if that's what i wanted to
do and be with
you know have the as my career it was
just something at the time was
for fun because like like i said the
first script i wrote is like a therapy
for a situation i was in at the time
my second script i wrote a superman
script not knowing that you can't write
you know material because of like
copyright infringements and stuff like
that i didn't know that it was a thing
yet at that time i was in my like
early 20s so didn't really know that you
couldn't
write a superman script and send it out
there but it was fun and
figured out what doesn't doesn't work in
the writing especially for action
sequences and
um but then by my my third and fourth
thing like i said i was
starting to write my own original
material at that point then and
that's when i became a screenwriter as
opposed to just somebody who has fun
doing it
you